[intro music]
Good morning, John. It's
Tuesday, February 6th.
Clean chin!
I'm really sorry, I didn't
realize that was going to be
quite that horrible.
Apparently wax is not
made for facial hair.
I've read
now online
some really horrible stories
about big chunks of skin
getting ripped off.
I had no idea, I'm so sorry.
That looked really horrible.
And also, extremely funny.
Three tries!
To get it
the first time
that, ugh
Well, at least those hairs won't
grow back for a while.
Or maybe
ever
since you may have done
some permanent damage.
Anyway,
during our tour of the entire
Southeastern United States,
Katherine and I have run
across several
babies.
And I can't help thinking about your response
to the "How do you feel about babies?" question.
You want an army of babies.
Dozens of babies.
But your only problem is you
don't know where to put babies.
That is NOT my only problem.
I have found the babies to be
rather adorable, though.
Katherine - "Look at Uncle Hank"
[Hank's baby voice] "Uncle Hank." I'm
Uncle Hank! I think that's adorable!
Yeah, when I married Katherine,
I became an uncle,
because Katherine's brother has a son.
So, when you have a baby, I won't be able to say,
"Oh, I'm an uncle now."
'Cause I'm already an uncle.
Sorry about that.
Anyway, now that I've
met a few
I actually
kind of
like them.
I've met a very interesting baby
here at Katherine's parents' house.
She's called "Baby Shingy".
I want you to listen very carefully
to what Baby Shingy has to say.
[string pulling]
Baby Shingy [garbled] - "Play pat-a-cake?"
Hank - "Play potty cake?"
[string pulling]
Baby Shingy [garbled] - "I'm sleepy."
Hank - "I'm stinky."
[string pulling]
Baby Shingy [garbled] - "Peek-a-boo!" [giggles]
Hank - "Chicken poo?" [giggles creepily]
This is the kind of
baby I want.
You can shake it and
it makes noises,
it's
scary-looking,
[rough breathing noise]
[whispers] Here I come, I'm scary baby.
[grunting noises]
I am still very excited about the
prospect of you having a baby, though.
So don't take the uncle thing the wrong way.
I'm especially excited about the
prospect of you having babies
because then mom maybe will stop
bothering me about it so much.
So,
how's that going for you?
I can think of a dozen great places to
put a baby inside of your apartment.
It could be fun!
Like, every day, Sarah comes
home, and you'll say,
"Find the baby!"
and she has to search through the entire
apartment trying to find where you hid the baby.
Wow,
having a baby's gonna be a lot of fun!
I hope you let me know as soon
as you have any news on that front.
Just like the time you called me five or
six minutes after you lost your virginity.
It's really important that you
share stuff like that with me.
Anyway,
I hope both of us are fertile and that
neither of us ever have to be punished again!
I'll see you tomorrow.